i'm joined now by athol johnson who's a
professor of clinical pharmacology at
queen mary university of london and
holly rubin who's a psychotherapist
specializing in body image welcome to
both of you holly rubin this is such a
tragic case just how unusual is it but
for people to take pills when they don't
necessarily know what the risks of them
are
it's unfortunately it's not so unusual
um however it's it's just a very tragic
case and
as a parent my heart goes out to
eloise's mom
but unfortunately the pressure to
have a certain body type and to fit into
a certain mold is so extreme and so
intense right now for
for adolescents and for people in
general so it's difficult well yes and i
thought johnson tell us a little bit
about this drug dnp what exactly is it
people keep calling it a drug but it
isn't it's an industrial chemical
originally it was used an explosive in
the first world war and in fact even at
that stage it was killing people it was
reckoned that 16 people died for every
10 000 tons of this material that was
made
in the
but 1930s it was discovered that it
the the use of energy in the body so
your your energy goes to waste
and therefore burns fat and it was
released as a drug for about five or six
years until they discovered that the
major problems with
killing people but also causing
cataracts even when it was used safely
uh so it was banned and that was some
time ago
1937 yes it was banned in the states and
it's still banned for human consumption
in this country but you can still get
hold of it can't you well it's an
industrial chemical it's used for a lot
of things so it's not difficult to get
hold of and i think eloise's mueller has
exactly right you can't you can't stop
its availability because we can get it
from on the internet we can buy it in
places that you just can't stop it being
available but what you can do is tell
people the risks and holly rubin that's
half the problem isn't it presumably the
fact that it's accessible and these days
so many things
are within people's reach because of the
internet exactly and i think the
internet itself
just
what we see and what we are constantly
bombarded with there's a it's a very
difficult it's very difficult for people
to gauge what's what's acceptable and
what's not what's real and what's not to
give us an idea of what's going on in
someone's head that makes them want to
take a pill that's not being prescribed
by their doctor
there could be so many things um but
what's certainly there is this drive to
um to lose weight and this this drive to
ascertain a um a certain
a certain image to fit in with what's
believed to be the the um the perfect
image which doesn't really exist at the
end of the day does it well no and how's
that got worse i mean are we worse now
than we were in any other generation
everyone's wanted to look like their
peers or look better than their peers
but surely that's always been there why
is it so much worse now that
it certainly has always been there but i
think what's happening now is because of
the um the way that the way that we are
exposed to technology and the images
that we are seeing that we are seeing so
regularly we're constantly being fed
information which is not even real which
these images which are being
photoshopped so people seeing what is uh
not truly there
is driving
this need and i thought johnson
presumably the importance is to
communicate as we were saying the risks
of some of these chemicals how do you go
about doing that and how difficult is it
for doctors as well to pick up on this
when as one doctor that we heard in the
report there suggested it's impossible
to know whether or not someone's taking
these pills well that's the problem
unless your
patient tells you what they're taking
you don't know or or maybe they're not
even your patient because you haven't
seen them recently and they're taking
these so that programs like this are are
exactly what's needed it needs to be
publicized that there are problems of
taking things if you're buying them off
the internet and you don't know what
you're taking or what dose to take
because that seems to be the major
problem here and what about for doctors
themselves we know that in this case
eloise took herself to a e but it was at
such a stage that the doctors couldn't
do anything when she got there it was
impossible to reverse the damage that
was being done
are doctors fully aware of how to
approach this kind of issue
well they just would with that with this
drug it's just not treatable with the
amount of that she took it was just not
not possible to to save her
unfortunately because she poisoned her
system
and there is no antidote
so holly rubin how do you go about
addressing this issue in in people young
and old whether they're
teenagers trying to lose weight whether
they're
middle-aged men trying to become
bodybuilders how do you go about
tackling it
awareness again programs like these
education the importance of
challenging these ideals and challenging
these body ideals and getting people to
feel more comfortable in who they are
and
the acceptance on body diversity and
being able to change what we're seeing
so that
we can feel more accepted in what we
appear okay